hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar
flow cytometric gene mutation assay made
possible by immunomagnetic separation
achieves oecd regulatory status
I am Cassie saltman of lab roots and
I'll be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by labroots and brought to you
by miltoni biotech
to learn more visit miltonybiotech.com
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation to do so simply
type them into the ask a question box
and click Send
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation you may also submit any
technical issues here as well if you
have trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation
I'd like to now welcome our speakers
Jeffrey Bemis director of clinical
studies lytron Laboratories and Joe
austrid flow cytometry specialist with
miltoni biotech Jeffrey you may now
begin your presentation
okay thank you very much for that
introduction and we'll just jump into
these slides
so I'm going to start out if you're not
familiar with us with a quick
introduction to lytron we've been doing
genetic toxicology for over 40 years
primarily our approach is in the
development of new assays and novel
methodologies the bulk of that is really
done in pre-clinical product safety but
we do have some clinical applications
for our methods as well as you'll see
throughout the course of this talk we
are very flow cytometry Centric so all
of our essays to date have been produced
to use flow cytometric instrumentation
okay
the broad theme for today is that
automated assays in instruments are
going to yield better information for
you and your studies this can come out
as improved compound characterization
they can be a complement or they can
achieve regulatory required assays and
I'll give you an example of that later
it can greatly expand the range of
information or the type of data that
you're going to be generating from your
studies and that can help you make
decisions about what to move forward and
what might be a hazard for you and then
finally they can address many of the
three R's initiatives and I'm sure
you're familiar with these and it makes
a lot of sense when I start talking
about in vitro assays but even in the
case of the in Vivo assay that I'll be
describing today you can make better use
of the animals that you have to use or
they're going to be in your required
assays because of our ability to just
use a small amount of blood and get
multiple endpoints out of those animals
that are already used for the conduct of
your regular studies
specifically as the title said we're
going to be talking about gene mutation
assessment in red blood cells now this
is commercially marketed as our in Vivo
mutaflow assay and I'm going to start
out with a basic introduction to what
that assay is
if you're familiar with this essay at
all you may and you probably have heard
it referred to as the pig a assay that
pig a comes from the gene that we take
advantage of to create this assay and
that's the phosphatidyl inositol glycan
complementation group a gene or the pig
a gene it's specific and is is critical
in the formation of GPI anchors and
these anchors are structures that are
used to attach specific types of
proteins to many different types of
cells in this case uh you know for this
assay we're going to be talking about
the surface of red blood cells this Gene
is also causal in the human disease
peroxismal nocturnal hemoglobinuria or
pnh and much of the biology that we
understand about the assay that I'll be
describing today has actually come from
Research into that particular human
affliction
the other characteristic that makes this
critical the pig a gene
um an advantageous Target for this assay
is that it is located on the X
chromosome so that means whether you're
an XX female and one of those X
chromosomes is silenced or you're an XY
male and therefore you only have one X
chromosome
it only takes one hit to kind of produce
this cell surface phenotype that I'm
going to describe and show you on the
next slide so it's really more of a rare
event type of analysis as opposed to say
an autosomal you know expressed
chromosome or an Express Gene where you
would have two or more copies per cell
and therefore to knock both of those out
you would have to have
it would be a very very extremely rare
event so in this case we're kind of
taking advantage of the one copy of the
pigei gene per cell and therefore we can
reduce that down to assessment of a
phenotype that can be reliably assessed
by a standard flow cytometric you know
antibody uh cell labeling type of
process and what that looks like here is
kind of shown on this slide here
we're doing this in red blood cells as I
described before so I'm taking that
specifically here and on the left hand
side of the slide we have that structure
we have the plasma membrane that you can
see here in the small rectangle inserted
into that is the GPI anchor so there's
that structure that is used to tag the
cd59 which is that protein that we're
showing here as a GPI anchored protein
on the surface of those red blood cells
and
it's kind of simple here on the right
hand side the mutant phenotype none of
that is there that cell could be
expressing all of the cd59 that it
possibly could but it will never be
trafficked and and adhered to the
surface of those red blood cells because
the GPI anchor wasn't formed because the
pig a gene wasn't functional in that
particular mutant cell this is just a
quick diagram of that to show you this
is the phenotype that we are assessing
by Float cytometry by and we move back
over to the left-hand slide or left-hand
side of the slide
we incubate the cells with a standard
fluorescently conjugated antibody
against that cd59 and run a standard
fluocytometric assay as you would
for any type of these cell surface
markers
what would we actually get out of that
when we run that what kinds of output do
we get well starting over on the left
hand side of the slide again we were
looking at red blood cells and in fact
we look at two different types of red
blood cells we look at reticulocytes
which are the less mature the retic the
red blood cells that are just coming out
of the bone marrow and that is
considered our leading indicator of
mutation here so if we look at the plot
here or the um the line graph down along
the bottom we have days of exposure to
enu which is a well-known
well-established mutagenic agent this is
in wistar rats and then we're looking at
the average number of cd59 negative so
these are the mutant reticulocytes that
we're looking at here on the y-axis and
you can see here by about you know day
10 or so we're starting to see
elevations in those reticulocytes at
different concentrations you know it's a
dose response and a Time related fashion
we're seeing increased mutation
frequency in the reticulocytes OR mutant
output right there
we move over to the middle of the slide
and we're looking at the more mature
erythrocyte so these this is the bulk of
the red blood cells that exist in the
periphery and as you can imagine there
are so many of those cells in there it
takes quite a bit of time for those
mutants to say turn over and to actually
sort of become frequent enough in that
population to be detected and therefore
you can see we're starting to see
significant elevations right out at
about 28 days to 48 days or so that's
where we really begin to see the major
impact on that much larger more mature
red blood cell population so we sort of
have these two indicators this leading
indicator and lagging indicator of
mutation within the red blood cells we
also get information on just the
frequency of the reticulocytes
themselves so not the mutant
reticulocytes per se but the combination
of the mutants plus the wild types and
this isn't necessarily so much an
indicator of the mutation that might be
happening in the system but more it's a
reflection of sort of toxicity in the
bone marrow and in fact it can help you
determine and in fact prove that you've
actually gotten your test article that
you gave to the to the test system
you've actually targeted it and gotten
it to the bone marrow and you're having
some sort of an effect in a depreciation
of reticulocytes a Toxic effect in the
bone marrow is being reflected here just
in the frequency of reticulocytes in
general so those are the three standard
parameters that we get out of our essay
so it seems pretty straightforward and
it sounds like you know just a standard
you know antibody combine it with cells
type of assay that you would be doing by
flow cytometry that most float
cytometrists would be familiar with but
as I'll show you here on the next couple
of slides we were presented with several
methodological challenges that we had to
overcome and the biggest one of those is
reflected here this is sort of what
we're calling the basic setup the assay
that we when we started it out and began
the initial development of this assay we
ran into this complicating Factor
and you can see it here because the
number of red blood cells that we were
looking at is around a million per cell
or per sample so per blood sample that
we took from an individual animal we
were getting about a million uh red
blood cells those are the mature
erythrocytes that we were looking at we
were getting about you know 0.3 times 10
to the sixth
um
of the reticulocytes that's a much less
populous
um portion of the red blood cells in the
periphery therefore as one would expect
we're counting a lot less of those it
would take us about 20 minutes per
sample to do this analysis to get that
number of red blood cells and
reticulocytes probably you know kind of
long for many people to sit there in
front of the flow for a single sample
but you know in this case we were hoping
to get some useful information out of
that ultimately this resulted in
relatively low accuracy and precision
putting those values on there because
as you can see here
there was a very low spontaneous
frequency of pig a mutation as a
baseline And as you can imagine here the
the the Baseline was right around one
per million cells so if you can see that
we're trying to develop that and and
accurately score that value that
frequency in those reticulocytes but
we're scoring less than a million you
can imagine we saw a lot of zeros in
that and that's really hard to actually
put numbers on and run statistics on if
a significant number of zeros are coming
through in your system this just really
wasn't making this a feasible approach
to accurately and reliably quantify the
populations that I was just describing
on that previous slide
so to overcome that issue I was just
describing we are going to employ the
milteni Supercar magnetic columns and
we're going to enrich for the particular
population that we're interested just
like that technology is used in any
number of other applications I'm going
to show you specifically how we do that
and then combine it with the flow
cytometric technology that milteni
presents in their instrument line of
flow cytometers so here you can see a
relatively complicated slide but I'm
going to reduce it really down to a
pretty simple Concept in that we label
the wild type cells the bulk of the
population of those red blood cells and
reticulocytes that are in the blood
sample with
an anti-pe microbead those are the Super
Pair of magnet or those are the beads
that get used in combination with those
columns to then hold up that population
on the column so we're really reducing
the vast majority of cells we're holding
them up on the column and we're eluding
out the population that we're really
interested in focusing on the wild type
cells a few of the wild type cells do
come through excuse me but the the all
of the mutant cells the mutant
reticulocytes and the mutant Redbud
cells come through and then we can label
them again with a bead solution that
allows us to enumerate the wild type
cells that are there the mutant cells
that are there the beads that are there
and come up with a mutant red blood cell
to bead ratio a mutant reticulocyte to
bead ratio and then compare that to a
sample that we took prior to the column
do a little bit of mathematics and
ultimately come up with the indication
of the mutant cell population in that
entire blood sample so we virtually
score a significant increase in the
number of cells that we can run through
the flow cytometer and I'll show you the
math on that in a little bit what it
really looks like on the flow cytometer
is shown here
over on the left hand side of the slide
this is our pre-column sample so we took
a sample of the blood before we ran it
through the column it's already been
labeled with all the antibodies and
beads that are required for the column
separation and you can see here on the
right hand side of this plot is the
significantly large population of the
wild type cells so that's the
predominant population that's there
that's the one that in a sense is sort
of clouding all of the assessment of the
mutant population that is over on the
left hand side in that red circle you
can see there are some of them there but
it's quite difficult to actually put a
significant or a good number on that
that's reliable when
we're actually looking for a good number
on that population so this happens to be
an enu treated animal so there's a
significantly large number of those
um that cell population there so that's
why you're actually seeing them show up
in this population when we move over to
the post column where again we've held
up the vast majority of those wild-type
cells you can still see some of them are
there and in fact we want some of them
there so we can use them to position our
quadrants appropriately but we can focus
much more reliably and efficiently on
the left hand side of that plot and look
at the mutant populations of the
reticulocytes and the red blood cells
and as you can see there it's much
easier and more efficient for us to put
a reliable number on that population
ultimately how does this compare to that
basic method that we were describing
before
this is the same portion of the slide
that I was showing previously we get
that you know million red blood cells
significantly less than a million
reticulocytes now with the mutaflow
system we can count over a hundred
million of these red blood cells three
million reticulocytes per sample we can
do it significantly faster so we're not
on the flow cytometer for 20 minutes per
sample it's around you know four minutes
per sample much more reasonable time
input on the machine and as you can
imagine this results in significantly
higher accuracy and precision associated
with the numbers that we can achieve
with this new approach using the multani
columns
this then really allowed us to reduce
this assay to practice and get it out
there in the in Commerce in the form of
our kits and our services so this was
really what made it possible for us to
develop a viable assay for the
assessment of mutational uh damage in an
animal system
speaking of those kits specifically well
how do you know maybe it's just lytron
that's sort of really good at this how
do we sort of prove that other people
can sort of take these kits out and use
them we do a lot of a lot of these
transferability demonstrations and in
this case we're going to look over at
the left hand part of the slide first we
did an experiment with some colleagues
from GSK and Covance and we sent them
the kits we all exposed animals to
either untreated controls or that enu
compound again a well-established
mutagen that was going to cause
significant elevations in those two
populations uh the mutant reticulocytes
and the mutant red blood cells in this
case we're actually looking at the cd59
negative mutant red blood cells
you can see here very great very nice
agreement between the different groups
so we were all looking at our Baseline
controls there in the untreated controls
and we're looking at significant
elevations but very consistent and
reliable numbers that we were able to
put on those elevated values due to the
enu exposure across those different
Laboratories again using all of the same
reagents that came from lytron we dig a
little deeper into the data and we can
look in this case specifically just at
lytron's values and those from GSK what
we're doing in this case is we took
the same Bloods that we were looking at
in that previous plot and we mix them
together at various delusions and we're
looking at an expected cd59 Count versus
what we actually measured and you can
see here excellent correlations between
um the expected versus the measured
values great R correlation coefficients
at both lytron and at GSK we took it a
little bit further and we did a bland
Altman analysis and we can see here you
know very low bias very narrow and
consistent and reliable
accuracy and agreement within those
methods across the different groups so
really a great assessment of performance
in the transferability or the ability
for other Laboratories to conduct this
assay
so we've got the essay we've got it
together well what do I actually what do
people actually do with this and how
does it sort of get out there into the
wild and start having an impact on the
kind of work that we're doing here I'm
going to talk about that in the context
of these sort of regulatory challenges
because ultimately the best place or the
greatest impact that we've had with this
assay has been in sort of these
regulatory safety studies that are being
done for you know Pharmaceuticals
industrial chemicals etc for their
safety submissions and therefore once it
gets through the sort of regulatory
framework and kit can work within that
regulatory framework it'll probably get
much greater acceptance
so on this part of the the talk I'm
going to sort of describe the The Saga
that we went through in order to get
this as a oecd you know worldwide test
guideline on how to conduct the pig a
assay so starting all the way back
really at the beginning of where I was
talking about the development of the
assay we were doing those
interlaboratory trials we looked at you
know upwards of 70 different chemicals
across multiple different Laboratories
it took us a number of years you can see
at least five years we spent on doing
those types of interlaboratory Trials
and in the middle of that we had to sort
of gather back again and refigure that
out and reconfigure it for use with the
with the column technology ultimately we
got that together and we got it working
uh very well and so we proceeded forward
we were looking uh at the assessment and
performance of the essay in the context
of several of these iwgt and Hesse gttc
they're basically just expert working
groups that all came together to look at
the data to look at the different you
know performance assessments that have
been done across the different
Laboratories and really judge whether or
not this thing was again worthy of
moving forward into an oecd guideline
ultimately it was judged to be quite
successful and then we started going
through the process of of submitting an
spsf in 2014 getting a work group
together in 2015 these are all under the
guidance of the oecd framework the
detailed review paper was submitted to
the oecd in 2017 ultimately expert
working group was formed within the oecd
to comment and to create the wording
that goes into the um the guideline the
detailed review paper a retrospective
performance analysis were all approved
in 2018. the the drafts of the exact
guideline were circulated around 20 to
21 and revised and commented on by all
the different um stakeholding countries
that are in the oecd and then ultimately
this was accepted
as a oecd approved test guidance in 2022
so very recent acceptance for this assay
here it is right here here's a here's
the oecd 470 test guideline this is a
picture of the cover of it and you can
see the title mammalian erythrocyte Pig
a gene mutation assay
ultimately what this does is it
describes the use of these methods which
includes the multi-flow assay which is
you know commercially available and was
the one that was developed at lytron in
how it gets used as part of regulatory
safety studies
this serves really as a guideline
primarily for Pharma and chemical
companies in their industrial uses you
can use it as part of standard product
development so if you have an issue with
say you got a an aims positive or some
sort of indication of mutation and some
of your in vitro assays this would be a
great follow-up to that one of the
places where it served greatly out in
the um in the Pharma Community
especially most recently has been in the
context of impurities in the production
of their Pharmaceuticals if you're
familiar with this this um this issue
that has kind of been plaguing
um Farmer for a number of years
the steps in the some of the examples
that I'm showing here talk about the
inclusion of the pigue assay as a useful
tool uh was laid out in the ich M7
guidance which is sort of a guidance for
Pharma on how to deal with impurities
and how to you know manage those types
of things in the product
um in the development of their products
it was used quite effectively in this
Pharma Consortium of a group of number
of different pharmaceutical companies
that came together to look at the impact
of buronic acids on some of their
synthetic processes and then very
recently you may have been aware of the
impact of nitrosamines as these
mutagenic compounds that get formed in
the synthesis of certain types of
pharmaceuticals and can be
um impurities and can be contaminants in
certain Pharmaceuticals and they need to
be controlled at very specific levels
and we need to understand whether there
is a hazard associated with those and
again the pig a assay was had played a
great role in that particular exercise
so to conclude our Vivo mutiful assay is
able to deliver mutation assessment in
red blood cells and reticulocytes in an
avivo system to give you that gene
mutation endpoint that you may be
looking for for your regulatory safety
studies this is easily accomplished by
flow cytometry as I described to you now
that we have that mutiflow system that
incorporates the scoring of a efficient
number of blood cells in each of those
populations
e to that and critical to that was that
column based isolation that I described
and it is going to be talked about a
little bit later in this presentation
a couple of other endpoints specific to
this beautiful essay is the integration
of this assay into ongoing toxicology
studies I mentioned that way back at the
beginning of this that small amount of
blood that you need to assess this
endpoint really makes it easy for you to
sort of drop into say a 28 day repeat
those toxicology study and get this in
addition to all of the other endpoints
that you're looking for so you don't
have to do dedicated genotoxicity
studies like you might have used to in
the past and we've developed it for
primarily the standard laboratory you
know mammalian species that you're going
to be looking at rat and mouse and a
couple of other species as well
so what are the takeaways from my part
of the of the assessment here the uh the
talk
this combination of advanced assays and
state-of-the-art Technologies is
obviously quite powerful it was critical
that we used that column based
enrichment to achieve the numbers that
we were looking for and then you can
synergize that with the high throughput
instrumentation that milteni and other
flow cytometry um instruments have and
that was really the key to delivering a
viable and reliable assay for the
assessment of mutation in Vivo
this beautiful assay has ultimately
turned out to be a highly accurate and
reliable gene mutation assessment
methodology it is available in kits that
are um that come with our QC reagents
that come with a significant amount of
technical support we've also have it as
a service so that if you don't have the
flow cytometry or the expertise to do
that kind of thing in-house you can
contract with us or a number of other
cross that can conduct the assay and
actually get those values for you if you
aren't able to take receipt of the kits
and do it yourself
yeah so I just want to
acknowledge a couple people at lytron
that have been instrumental in the
development of practically all the
assays that electron but primarily the
pig a assay that we were talking about
earlier uhlana ablesevich Dorothea
Taurus Steve Bryce and Steve dirtinger
are really the main people who have
contributed significant amounts of time
uh and effort to develop this assay and
this was I also want to acknowledge that
this was done in the context of our sbir
funding that came from the nihs several
different grants contributed to
over the years the development of this
pig a assay and to to Really reduce it
down to the functional system that we
have available today
thank you Jeffrey for your presentation
we're now going to pass things over to
Joe Austin our next presenter Joe you
may now begin your portion of the
presentation
all right thanks for that awesome
introduction Jeff and really cool depth
into that assay as well
um my name is Joe I'm from melteni uh
we've actually provided a lot of the
equipment to help support this assay and
um some of the core technologies that
melteni are critical to making this
essay successful and I'm going to be
taking a few moments to describe one the
magnetic enrichment technology that
allowed for
selection of cells and then two some
details on our cytometer the max Quant
10 and how that helps support the the
gene talks workflows as well as many
cell-based assays I've been with meltini
for about five years now on both the
technical team and and now as a senior
cytometry specialist so I feel like I
understand these Technologies quite well
and yeah we'll have some time at the end
for questions but I'm basically going to
go over some of miltoni's main
Technologies and um and and hopefully in
a little bit of detail so that even if
you've used them before you may learn
something new and for those of you
completely new to miltenny I hope this
is a good background on on what we do
so to start with miltoni is a a company
that really works in the translational
space so we have a variety of
Technologies uh both on the reagent side
and the instrumentation side that help
researchers develop Technologies develop
assays and then transition them to a
regulated environment and uh sorry our
sort of main slogan for that is from
benchtop to bedside so we we really
pride ourselves on our ability to
transition Technologies and transition
assays to this regulated environment and
we have a huge support team to help make
that possible
um if you're working with cells if
you're working with tissues these slides
are meant to show that we we can go from
something as big as a tissue break it
down using the gentlemax which is our
instrument in the top left work through
a variety of cell preparation strategies
whether that's isolation or activation
maybe culturing and then going through
and and looking at those cells and
seeing how they've changed in that
process
for the purpose of this discussion I'm
not going to get into every single
technology or every single piece of
equipment but I am going to be focusing
primarily on the magnetic activated cell
sorting technology this is if most
people if you've heard of miltoni you
know us for this technology and um like
I mentioned I'll also be talking about
the cytometer because that's really my
area of expertise
so starting first with the magnetic
technology this was really what melteni
was founded on so Stefan milteni
developed this technology in 1989 or a
really uh marketed this technology
created a an industry around it and
effectively what it
is is a magnetic particle attached to an
antibody that would be specific for a
cell type of Interest so that allows you
to attach a magnetic particle to a cell
and then use a magnet to help enrich or
deplete that specific cell out of your
starting material so this has been
influential really field changing with
respect to your ability to work on
individual cells or individual types of
cells and it's also created a whole
clinical Market as well and really
Beyond just the clinical Market it's
created clinical therapies that have
helped people with a variety of disease
states that you need to enrich for cells
for so I I think um it's been really
remarkable to be a part of miltoni to
see how this field has grown just with
even in the last five years I think
maltani's probably doubled in size since
I joined
um simply because of how profound and
how
simple it is to work with these uh
microparticles I'm going to go into a
little bit of detail on on how these
things work and why they're particularly
helpful in this context but um in order
for them to work in order for a
meltene's version of this to to work
well we have kind of three main
components we have the microbeads which
I've just described the magnetic
particle with the antibody attached we
have a column which you will run that
now magnetically bound cell population
through I'll go into some detail about
how those columns work and then the
separator which is the actual big magnet
that we use to help
generate a magnetic field and make that
separation occur
so moving on to the next slide here
we've got
um a zoom in on these micro beads so the
micro beads are 50 nanometers they're
they stay in suspension which is what
colloidal means so it's nice they don't
like drop out in your uh tube I know
I've uh using these in the past I always
took them up to make sure they were
resuspended but I've since learned since
joining melt any that you actually don't
need to shake them up they're uh they're
super small so this is the major
difference between us and maybe any
other magnetic microbead particle
technology you've used ours are
incredibly small so that means uh one we
don't have to bind up every single
antigen on the outside of your cells
and two it means that they don't
necessarily activate the cells as
readily as some of those bigger
particles
so in that regard your cells are more
useful for Downstream assays so if
you're not binding every antigen that
means some antigens are available for
binding flow cytometry assay or binding
flow cytometry
antibodies too with fluorescent dyes it
also because they're so small they're
actually able to be digested by the
cells too so at some point they're
internalized and actually broken down by
many different cell types so in the
regulatory sense those particles are
actually not of concern to be a part of
the your final clinical product which is
really interesting so as stated here
they're non-toxic they're biodegradable
and biocompatible so I think these all
make for a very translational technology
a very something that's really High
utility across the field
now in order for the microbeads to work
because they're so small we use a a
column to help encourage a stronger
magnetic field so I'd still get the same
amount of Separation pull without having
these large beads which affect cell
livelihood and viability so in a
simplest sense we label the cells with
the magnetic particle we do the
separation via a column and then you
elude out your cells of interest there
are a couple ways that this can happen
either via
uh depletion or separation but they all
take advantage of this uh column
magnetic force
growth so we're using magnetic particles
in these columns and the columns
themselves uh simply
expand that magnetic force so by using
the column you're able to use these
smaller magnetic particles which have a
lot of advantages
The Columns have plenty of room in them
for cells to go through sometimes people
are curious about if we're losing cells
in the process of even just going
through the column but for the most part
the the space between the
beads that are packed in the column is
plenty for for cells to move through
which is important because we we really
need cells to move through the column
freely in order for this to work well so
we've got a couple of
quick examples to show positive
enrichment and negative enrichment
sometimes called depletion and so these
two are are really the the core ways
that we use these columns to um
to to enrich for cells effectively
this little diagram will show positive
selection in this case where we've
labeled the cells that we want so in the
diagram we're going to be looking for
the green cells the green ones are the
ones that we want in this graphic and
they've been bound with the magnetic
particle and so when the magnets being
applied the cells that you want stick in
the column and everything else washes
through so this is really nice for a
really clean High Purity enrichment
um and the the caveat of course is that
you've used an antibody to bind to your
cells I think in many cases this binding
is not a big deal to the cells of
interest but some people like their
stuff with nothing bound to it for a
variety of reasons so again this is
showing just the positive selection
binding to the the column itself
um the other way we can do this is
called the negative isolation sometimes
like I said called a depletion in this
case we were looking for the purple
cells sorry I think we're yeah we're
looking for the purple cells in this one
um and we've used antibodies to bind up
every other cell type that's in there uh
and those other cell types will stick in
the column and the cells we want are
going to process through to the bottom
and that illusion is what will take away
so in this case we've got a really nice
uh clean or untouched population that
we've enriched for
um the tricky part for this one is that
you need to make sure you have an
antibody for every single other cell
that's in there so if you don't account
for some specific cell type in your
population it may allude out with your
cells of Interest so these are all
things we've thought about all the way
through in the development of these
products so this is not a surprise and
certainly our pre-built kits will
absolutely have every antigen you need
to
to bind up cells that are not wanted in
this regard these have a bit more
um
difficulty or complication to go into a
translational Market because of how many
different reagents or antibodies are
involved with the depletion but that's
certainly something that we could talk
about if anybody's interested in making
that transition
so all of these technologies that
utilize the column
um it is the core technology for miltoni
so as you may imagine we have a variety
of formats that these come in and these
help researchers support either very
small scale or entry-level
research-based enrichments all the way
up through
huge taking down big blood Pro big blood
products from patients or donors and um
and doing this in a really high
throughput format we also have
technologies that make things either
more automated or simpler to use or with
fewer total reagents so overall there's
pick your flavor right so no matter what
you're working on we may have something
that's really tuned to your need so
starting on the left we have our the low
throughput this is just a plastic column
that you would run through just a single
sample
uh the the one to the left is basically
4X that I think there's even one that's
yeah you can take four columns and stick
them in there the columns come in a
variety of sizes too based on your needs
um in the middle is the Automax this is
a an automated system that will process
and spit your cells out for you without
really any Hands-On time which is super
nice uh next to that is the multi-max 24
which allows you to basically Multiplex
do
um a lot of these enrichments at the
same time and process through up to I
believe as as high as a Luca pack in a
single process which is really
convenient if you're trying to do a
large scale enrichments and then um at
the extreme side we have a fully
automated system that will do liquid
handling and processing of large blood
products and spit out a huge variety of
things so these things have
um
yeah I mean really anywhere you fit in
this scale there's something for you and
um and it may be very very easy to work
with as well
so moving on from the magnetic
technology which I think we've just got
described in plenty of detail
um the essay that the the pig assay that
we talked about utilizes cytometry in a
gene talk setting which is a nice
transition cytometry is really great for
this uh world and it's something that
it's been exciting to see adopted by
more and more of these um Technologies
it's just such a
you get so much data so quickly with the
cytometer and I really think it's a
perfect technology for this type of work
so we're going to talk a little bit
about our cytometer the max Quant we
have a variety of
types of cytometers that fall under the
max client designation but um we'll talk
about
our cytometer and how they fit well into
this environment
so
I I mentioned that
Gene talks are really toxicology in
general is starting to to adopt
cytometry over microscopy and there's a
huge there's a few very important
reasons why that is I mentioned it's
faster so you can process thousands of
events in a single second
um this is by microscopy is incredibly
challenging
um and it oftentimes a cytometer can
give you a readout that is
um
easier to to comprehend to someone
that's maybe not an expert so you put it
in this a gate a cytometry gate it can
spit out yes or no whereas microscopy
there can be some uh interpretation that
is needed by somebody who's really got
an expertise for this
um cytometry can be automated in a much
simpler way than uh microscopy
and um you can also automate the proceed
the processing of multiple samples which
is really nice
so outside of cytometry as a whole the
max Quant specifically has a couple of
elements to it that I think are very
nice for this environment so first
because it's based on a syringe
um we have absolute cell counting which
means you can put your sample on there
and it's going to spit out not only the
frequencies of each of those populations
or the the plus minus positive versus
negative but it's also going to tell you
exactly how many cells and the
concentration of those cells in your
material so if you're looking at a
killing assay you need you to say how
many cells are left over if you're
looking at
um really anything that requires you to
quantify the number of cells in there
um you can do that very simply so we've
written on the slide it saves money
which is of course true if you're not
buying counting beads but counting beans
are also a huge pain to work with so if
you're able to remove those from your
um your assay then that's really
advantageous
the max con also has a very small dead
volume so dead volume is uh additional
material that needs to be put into the
cytometer in order to measure your
sample correctly so let's say if you
have a standard cytometer and you're
measuring 20 microliters of your
material you may need to add up to 50
microliters more in order to measure
that effectively and that that number
can go very high depending on how much
automation you're using whereas the max
con we're much lower than that so in any
case this is very nice if you have
limited amount of sample
maxcon also has onboard washing so that
minimizes carryover from one sample to
the next so if you are looking at very
very rare events or the presence of an
event is particularly impactful to your
ability to either release product or
qualify your material in a QC setting
the the carryover can be
um it can make your assay a lot less
reliable if your carryover is not
accounted for so with the max client you
can automate a cleaning cycle that
brings our carryover down to point zero
one percent Which is far lower than
anything else on the market
we've also worked with lytron
uh for quite a long time to develop
automated templates that work with
lytron kits so this is overall okay
we're talking about technology on the
cytometry side it's all great but what
you end up really really wanting is a
partnership with the of the assay kit
Builder and the technology or the
instrument Builder and so the fact that
we've worked with vitron so closely
throughout this process is incredibly
valuable to the end user because if
you're troubleshooting problems a lot of
times if the companies don't communicate
if they're not collaborating
um you get sort of a finger pointing
thing where you're not sure if it's the
kid's fault or the instrument's fault
and because they're not working together
they may not give you a great responses
but
both the lytron team and the military
team have a great understanding of both
of our portfolios to the point where we
can give really really
um detailed support on any of the assays
that you're using between our um
companies which is really great and it
I've worked with a handful of folks over
at lytron and it's always been a really
easy easy thing to work with so
definitely this is probably my favorite
part about
um our technology in this space
so I mentioned we have a few Max quants
we have the max Quant 10 which is our
kind of our Flagship cytometer this is
something that I think is really robust
in the QC environment something that is
very easy to use for new cytometry
people
um and basically it checks off all the
boxes that I've just mentioned
um also in our scope is the max Quant X
this is a high throughput version that
basically runs 384 well plates as well
um so we can
um accommodate whatever scale you need
on the analyzer as well these are
they're good systems we've got good cell
counting we are easy to work with easy
to maintain and we have a couple
versions with respect to a number of
channels you might need so if you're
doing something like immunofenotyping we
may have more uh channels for you than
somebody just doing a one color
toxicology assay
everything's run off of the pipetta
needle here which is fairly different
from any of the other cytometers on the
market this one allows for really good
volume characterization but also lets us
do mixing in the plate it lets us switch
between plates and tubes really easily
so any of that stuff is is very
straightforward to use if you are using
tubes we have a rack that is chilled so
you can put it in the fridge and keep
your samples at a cool temperature while
you're operating so this can be really
helpful if your assay is very
temperature dependent
uh and we have a reagent rack here which
you'll see on the bottom right which
allows you to actually automate some of
the either antibody additions or a
viability Die edition which um is super
nice if you're in this setting it's
often that you're developing an assay
that's going to be done over and over
and over again so some of these really
simple automation strategies can speed
up your assay or remove some of the
um requirement for an additional head
count to do this kind of thing
all right I'm going to bring up all
these at once because I think they're I
don't necessarily want to read every
single one but miltoni's done a lot in
this space so there's cell based assays
are a huge part of what our
magnetic enrichment is used for and so a
lot of our cytometry therefore is
designed to support these assays as well
we have screening assays immunogenicity
assays which I think are becoming more
and more popular by flow
um toxicology screening is of course
important this is probably why a lot of
you are on the call to begin with this
micronucleus test is one that we have uh
many many cytometers in the field to
support so we really run the gamut on
these cell-based assays I find that in
general you're not using a huge amount
of color so you don't need a crazy
five laser system but you need something
that's going to work for you and
continue to work for you over a period
of time so
um if you have if you see assays on here
that you are using and you want to get
in touch with us absolutely let us know
if there's other assays that you're
you're not sure if you can put into flow
let us know too we all these came from
somewhere right so it's we have
application development scientists that
can work with you to
to take something that's a maybe a
microscopy assay now that you want to
automate
um those are all fun projects for us so
definitely let us know
so finally we've got a small set a small
cytometer it's
got all the lasers you would need for
most toxicology assays we have lots of
different ways to run tubes it's easy to
operate and one thing that I haven't
touched on is we have a really
integrated support so that's Live
support where we will
um
either be on site working with you to do
application support but we also have a
button that you can click in the
software that will connect you to our
tech support team and they can actually
look at your screen if you give them
permission they can click around on your
screen and help diagnose any challenges
you're having and actually help
uh build out some of the data set you're
looking for too so all that stuff is
very simple to to connect with
um
and something that's really quite unique
to our system as well
so with that I'll wrap up on the milteni
side
um I have a slide up here to sort of
thank all the folks over at lytron and
my colleagues as well at meltini and
um I think our teams have worked really
nicely together as you can tell we're
doing a webinar together but the the
amount of stuff that lytron has done
with us is is quite big at this point so
we're we're really happy to be connected
with them and to continue doing work
like this and um yeah we're happy to
start taking any questions now and
um yeah we're yeah we'd love to hear
from you guys so thank you
thank you Jeffrey and Joe for your
informative presentation we will now
start the live q a portion of the
webinar if you have a question you'd
like to ask please do so now just click
on the ask a question box located on the
far left of your screen we'll answer as
many of your questions as we have time
for
let's get started our first question is
can the pig a assay be incorporated as
part of a repeat dose talk study
yeah so the the short answer for that is
yes I mentioned it very briefly towards
the end of my presentation uh and I was
specifically talking about say a 28-day
toxicology study which you know if if
you're familiar with that then it's
going to sound
um
like you know something that is is
fairly standard conduct for safety
assessment of pharmaceuticals and
Industrial chemicals Etc
um but to go into a little bit more
detail as to how we actually fit it in
there you heard me talk about a low
blood volume requirement for this pig a
essay specifically you really only need
a maximum it's somewhat species
dependent but
um
about 300 microliters of blood so you're
not it's not a very large ask in terms
of the volume of blood that you would
need to go towards this so that's fairly
simple for you to get
um from numerous routes in in rat or
Mouse
the other component of this that I
didn't get a chance to address is you
can take these samples and you can
process them fresh if you're running
them right in your laboratory you're
going to collect them and then run them
the same day you can keep the samples
fresh and you can run them immediately
or within several days so they're good
for about five days if you want to keep
them refrigerated maybe get to them the
next day after your collection but we
also have a means for freezing samples
and this is really
um a great Advantage for those talk
studies because you know maybe you're
conducting this study for for numerous
other reasons you're getting
histopathology you're getting
um TK PK all those different other
components that you generally get as
toxicology studies and maybe one of
those is the contributing factor to to
you know the the dropping of that
particular compound you blew out the
liver or something like that if you
froze our samples away for say pig a um
mutational assessment you don't have to
run them right away you can store them
for months at a time and get back to
them in that way if it comes up that you
needed to look at a mutation endpoint
later on you don't have to start a whole
other dedicated study and invest in all
the time and the resources to do that
again you simply dip into the freezer
where you froze those samples away
and you can get that mutation endpoint
so there's several characteristics of
this assay that really drive it home
towards that 28 day toxicology study and
in fact that was really the study design
that we used for the development of the
essay so the bulk of the data that are
out there and that you read in the
literature were based on 28-day
toxicology studies so it really is well
established for that paradigm
great thank you our next question is
what species are compatible with the pig
a assay
sure um I mentioned it again right
towards the end of my presentation I
think I said rodent studies
um we have kits and services specific
for rat that's probably the most common
test system that we work in and there's
a slightly different you know there's a
slight antibody change to go over to
Mouse so we can support both of those
very common laboratory-based species and
then the other
um system that we do have an assay
developed for is human and that sounds
kind of like a big leap to go you know
all the way from Mountain to human but
um first in human clinical trials
epidemiology studies you can see places
for that kind of technology that
approach that mutational assessment in
those sort of situations where you've
got populations that you want to be
looking at you may have some type of
exposure that you think may be causing
mutation this is the assay that you
could use for that directly in humans
and if you're if you're interested in
learning more about that definitely
contact us I can I can send you some of
the literature that we have published uh
and see some specific case examples of
how we use that technology in human
samples
right
that looks like this next question is
for Joe Joe can you describe a bit more
about the automated gating
yeah sure so if anybody's done cytometry
before I'm sure that's kind of what
motivated this question but um you're
you're tasked with sort of
isolating out the populations of cells
so to say these ones are positive these
ones are negative and depending on how
obvious that signal is you may be on the
hook to draw the line to say here's
where the negative stops and the
positive begins
um most researchers are comfortable
running controls to make that evaluation
but there's still some subjectivity to
where those gates are placed there's
also a convenience in having it done
automatically so melteni has a
technology called an Express mode which
I briefly mentioned but um basically
it's a custom algorithm trained on data
from your actual assay so it can it can
incorporate donor to donor variability
or really whatever the the flex is in
your assay itself and it will physically
draw the gates for you spit out
statistics spit out a variety of things
that maybe are manipulations of that
statistic into something as a readout
that you may use Downstream so
um super cool there's a lot of different
ones but um yeah they're they um
awesome thank you how does the cell
counting on the Mac squant work
yeah this is a I was talking a little
bit about the the counting beads before
um I'm not sure if I went into too much
detail about that but
um Counting beads are hard control that
you would add to your sample to help
qualify uh the number of cells in there
these were necessary on other cytometers
because there's they they don't qualify
the the volume going through very
accurately that's not a problem with the
max Quant because we we operate on a
syringe driven system basically think of
it like a a pipettor on board and um
a very precise understanding of how much
volume is going through and so that
coupled with the um
event detection or count done by the
cytometer itself allows you to to work
backwards and get a concentration super
easily again can spin out into like the
actual data analysis software too so I
can save a few steps
wonderful and it looks like we have time
for one more question
can the Mac squant be used for a
validated assay
yeah this is sort of a
um broad question I would say but it's a
an important designation to make that
um you you can use these in a regulated
setting
um there are a number of things that you
have to consider for that but um the
short answer is yes you can use this in
a there are there are Max constant
validated or regulated settings and we
have a a software package that's 21cfr
part 11 compliant or help support a
compliant workflow and um that includes
user management settings and Analysis
reports that are non that are human
readable and non-editable so um yeah we
have all the tools to help you get into
a validated setting and and certainly we
can help support that too if you're new
to that environment
fantastic thank you
um thank you both do either of you have
any final comments for our audience
Jeff you want to go first
yeah I just want to say thanks for um
you know attending and listening to the
presentation from uh both of our sides
uh like um Joe was mentioning earlier we
do have this really nice relationship
back and forth between lytron and
milteni and we've been trying to Foster
that for for years and it's served us
really well on both sides so we've got
the the methodology development and in
many cases we're developing a lot of our
essays for flow cytometry and we have
these instrumentation in-house so we
have several quants that we run our
essays on when we're developing so we
immediately know how well it's going to
work with these instruments and that's
just made a really nice sort of you know
back and forth when we're developing
these assays and I want to thank milteni
for the opportunity to to come and talk
about our essay as well
yeah thanks a lot Jeff I fully agree
um the connection between melteni and
lytron is a good one and and really
helps Foster new technologies or new
assays as well so yeah thanks everybody
for jumping on
um if you you should be able to find our
contact information
um certainly miltoni is easy to find
electrons easy to find
um so if there are additional questions
that you didn't get to
get answered today or something very
specific to your
um particular challenges uh just reach
out we're happy to answer questions it's
a big part of what we do so
um yeah thanks again for joining and we
appreciate your time
thank you again Jeffrey and Joe for your
time today and your important research
we would also like to thank lab roots
and our sponsor miltoni biotech for
underwriting today's educational webcast
before we go I'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions questions we
did not have time for today and those
submitted during the on-demand period
will be addressed by the speakers via
the contact information you provided at
the time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand lab
Roots will alert you via email when it's
available for replay we encourage you to
share that email with your colleagues
who may have missed today's live event
until next time goodbye